- [Narrator] Fast casual chain Cava
has turned Mediterranean dishes
into a nearly $4 billion business.
But most of its growth came
from an uncommon strategy:
buying a competitor quadruple its size
and converting all its
locations into Cavas.
(lively music)
- I like to say I went to bed
running about 70 restaurants
and woke up running over 250 restaurants.
- [Narrator] The strategy: turn Cava
into the country's biggest
Mediterranean restaurant chain,
leaving many to compare it
to where Chipotle was a decade ago.
Its success depends on how
long the Mediterranean diet
can remain popular.
The company says it's
using lots of customer data
to strategize where to open new locations,
but now that Cava can no
longer rely on an acquisition
to scale up, how can it continue
to grow at such an ambitious pace?
- Growth takes time, it's
expensive, it's variable,
and I think that's a little
bit of coming down to reality.
- [Narrator] This is
"The Economics of Cava."
Cava has been rapidly expanding for years.
- Cava really likes the suburbs.
They really see potential there,
and some of those communities
probably don't have other
Mediterranean food options
or readily, you know,
marketed to them options
that they might seek out.
- We've built a really
robust real estate model
that includes demographic
and psychographic analysis
and we then use mobile
analytics to understand
where our guests are coming
from, where they're going,
and then kind of create
a DNA of our guest base,
and then heat map that
DNA across the country
to then show us
where we have the highest
likelihood of success.
- [Narrator] In 2018,
Cava bought Zoe's Kitchen,
another chain of fast casual
Mediterranean restaurants,
for $300 million.
At the time, Zoe's Kitchen
had 261 locations compared
to Cava's more than 70,
but Zoe's kitchen was
burning through cash.
- It was a melting ice cube
and we didn't want it
to turn into a puddle.
- [Narrator] Zoe's Kitchen, Schulman said,
had lost its identity,
serving as a cautionary tale for Cava.
- I think over time,
Zoe's had lost its focus.
It had added many menu items.
I think the consumer was kind of confused
as to what the brand really stood for
and what their core
competency is versus at Cava,
we're really about these
modern Mediterranean flavors.
38 ingredients, very
simple, focused operation.
- [Narrator] Most of the
new restaurants Cava opened
from 2019 to 2023 came
from converting existing
Zoe's Kitchen locations.
This meant Cava could scale
faster and at half the cost
of building new restaurants from scratch.
- When we looked at the
Zoe's real estate portfolio,
we saw many sites across the
portfolio that we would love
as a Cava site that we felt
was really underperforming its potential.
So we felt like this would be a way
to rapidly expand our brand in a part
of the country we were
trying to enter into.
And we could do it in a much faster way
than if we were trying to
source these deals one by one.
- [Narrator] Cava converted
its last Zoe's Kitchen
in October 2023, which means that now
it has to build new
locations from the ground up.
Cava is currently in 24
states, plus Washington, D.C.,
and it went public in June 2023.
As it looks to grow, it hopes
to capitalize on the rising popularity
of the Mediterranean diet,
which it hopes to appeal
to a broad range of
customers across the country.
Right now, only 1.4%
of US restaurants primarily
serve Mediterranean cuisine.
In its last quarterly report,
Cava Group reported a net
income of $6.8 million
with a restaurant level
profit margin of 25.1%.
Cava is now the largest
Mediterranean style restaurant chain
in the country, but is
it the next Chipotle?
- Chipotle was really
taking Mexican nationwide
in a very unique way
that's an assembly line style
of creating burritos and bowls
and Cava is seeking to take
Mediterranean food nationwide
with also kind of more
of an assembly line,
fast casual style of service.
But Chipotle was getting going
when fast casual really was barely a blip.
So there was a lot less competition then.
Cava has a lot more competition now.
- [Narrator] Whether
the restaurant succeeds
may largely depend on
whether customers continue
to seek Mediterranean food.
- Mediterranean has gotten
a lot of good buzz, right?
It's seen as healthier,
it's good for the heart
and you know, overall body.
That said, it's still new.
Harissa, tahini, falafel,
for a lot of communities,
these are still new kinds of foods
and that's still a question mark.
Do people wanna eat
this day in and day out
as opposed to just trying it?
- As of October 2023,
Cava finished converting
all Zoe's kitchen locations
into Cavas but it's told investors
that it will continue growing
its number of locations
by at least 15% each year.
- I think the biggest question
is can they grow in the way
that they've said that they're going to
for their investors,
and do it organically?
Now they have to open their own
sites, find their own sites,
make sure the sites are good,
be able to afford paying
for this real estate and
construction costs and other costs.
- [Narrator] It plans to open
at least three restaurants in Chicago,
which will be its first
major foray into the Midwest.
It's targeting 47 to 50
new restaurants in 2024
with locations based
on a significant amount
of customer data.
- I think restaurants are
a blend of art and science,
and so we love the science part
and understanding how do we use data
to inform our decisions?
So it gives us great
visibility into being able
to take this brand to the 26
states we're not in today,
and to go broader and deeper
in the 24 states we already
currently operate in.
- [Narrator] But it's a difficult time
to be expanding a fast casual restaurant.
The economic slowdown has led
to many restaurants struggling,
and while chain establishments
are better positioned
than independent ones,
the market is saturated.
Despite this, Cava is planning
for a 15% growth in
store numbers next year.
- If you look at where US-based
restaurant chains are now,
I mean, Wingstop, which is mentioned
as the big growth engine
is at something like 11%,
and I believe Cava is
projecting even more.
So they have grown very quickly
and they've really promised
more growth at a very high rate.
And so investors are gonna be looking
for those numbers every year.
(lively music)